i also have a little bit of a
french-american comparison but it's a
touch buried I'm going to talk today
about wine grapes I just started my lab
a little over a year ago something to
tell you about my goal is to give you a
little overview of what the lab goes for
what we study what we're trying to
actually understand and then how wine
grapes fits into it and tell you about
the research program we have okay so to
get to the major question that my lab
addresses we have to start here this is
a figure I bet many of you are familiar
with this is from the intergovernmental
panel on climate change their 2007
working group one report and it is our
best estimate with a business-as-usual
scenario of the warming the earth will
experience over the next 80 years so by
the end of this century but I want you
to take away is twofold one note that
this legend on the bottom is in addition
to the warming already experienced so we
start at zero but zero is really a point
62.7 degree warming advance increase
that's already happened and secondly
take a look at the terrestrial biosphere
what we are projecting is a minimum
really of a two degree warming event
across the terrestrial system which
really is where most of our crops are so
this is a radical warming event I'm a
community ecologist I am broadly trying
to answer the question of how will plant
species respond to such radical changes
in warming that we are creating for them
we know there are two major things that
happen already and those are that wild
species tend to shift in space and they
tend to shift in time and my goal is to
try to better understand that with the
ultimate goal of can we predict it and
is there any hope of mitigating those
consequences and I funk I focused
primarily on changes in time and those
changes in time are phenological shifts
so phonology is the timing of recurring
life history events the day that a bird
starts its migration the day that a
first leaf comes out on your maple tree
in your backyard the day of first flower
it's also the timing of crop events so
the day that we sow seeds of wheat is a
phenological event it has human
influences but it's predominantly a
phonology event-related very strongly to
our crop systems and to humans it's also
the date of fruit maturation that's a
phenological event and the date of crops
their date of crop harvest and so I'm
really interested in how we can leverage
crop systems and in particular wine
grapes
to answer the question of how will wild
species actually shift with climate
change how can we better predict that
and I'll tell you why I use wine grapes
in two parts the first part is that wine
grapes are hyper diverse and yet
genetically very narrow so all the
different wine that you drink comes from
different varieties of wine grapes wine
grapes are a subspecies vitis vinifera
subspecies vinifera they are genetically
less diverse than even a species and
then we have varieties so Pinot Noir is
a variety of wine grape wine grape
cabernet sauvignon is another one so if
you like pinot you like one genetic
genotype basically of wine grape and if
you like Cabernet Sauvignon that's a
slightly different genetic part type of
wine grape and what we see is that these
are hyper diverse in their phonology so
different varieties of wine grape come
out at very different times of year so
these are data from winters California
where they've planted all together in a
garden about 1,500 different varieties
of wine grape there are arguably about
5,000 different varieties of wine grape
so I'm sure you've sampled only a tiny
tiny fraction no matter how hard you've
worked at it the number of varieties is
here on the vertical axis you can see it
goes up to 600 so a lot of different
varieties represented here but what I
want you to take away is the variation
here on the horizontal axis over a month
in the blue histogram of variation in
when these different varieties leaf out
and again that's genetically very little
variation yet phenological e huge
variation and then if we look at the
flowering in pink the mean bloom bloom
time again well over a month of
variation so I'm interested in this
because we want to understand not just
how phonology ships with climate change
but I argue that many many plant traits
shift with climate change and we tend to
use phenology as this major indicator
but we're actually seeing shifts an
entire syndrome so things like the
stomata that Missy just mentioned and so
I'm trying to leverage wine grapes to
understand that shift in plant syndrome
versus just phenological shift with
climate change let me give you an
example of why I think wine grapes are
good for this so here's one major trait
aspects of leaf shape these are two of
the earliest varieties of wine grape
this is Chardonnay over on the left and
Pinot Noir very early read over on the
right and then two of the latest
varieties cabernet sauvignon on the
bottom on the left and Barbara and
Italia
grape over on the right so these are
grapes that you harvest first they leave
out first they have short growing
seasons these are grapes you harvest
last they take a long growing season to
get them to maturity and to harvest them
and hopefully you see there is huge
phenological of leaf diversity here low
bang varies the two thing varies the
vein structure varies and so we're
trying to leverage wine grapes to
understand that we have a project going
on in Davis California 150 different
varieties planted together we monitor
multiple phenological stages throughout
the year to get working on that the
other reason I study wine grapes and I
think they're great for better
understanding phenological shifts with
climate change is that we have
tremendous phenological records of wine
grapes wine grape harvest records in
burgundy france go back to before 1300
so we have extremely long term data
which is quite rare obviously for humans
period and for phenology as well these
are the records going back to 1600 this
is a composite index of harvest records
from across ference the red line is just
a smoothing mean for five years and the
harvest date is relative to the first of
September so that 0 is when you harvest
on the first of September negative
numbers you harvest early positive
numbers you harvest late you can see
this signal of climate change at the end
and so these long term records let's let
us do a lot of things we can't usually
do we can do simple things like say what
actually triggers harvest date in wine
grapes and this is not surprising these
are correlations so a correlation index
here on the right for temperature on the
left and precipitation on the right
looking at May to July temperatures not
surprisingly these blue negative numbers
hotter summers lead to earlier harvests
and here looking at the Reds more
precipitation wetter summers lead to
later harvests this isn't shocking but
because we have these long-term records
we can do something can't usually do we
can start thinking about what are the
drivers of things we care about so early
harvests tend to be higher quality wine
it's not that every early harvest is the
best vintage but in general if you
harvest early it is a very good
predictor of how high quality that wine
will be and how much you will sell it
for per bottle in France so these are
climate composites of all the years
where the harvest was ten days earlier
than average
significantly early harvest and their
composites we're just looking at the
mean response across all these early
harvest years so temperature again on
the right a measure of soil moisture or
drought the Palmer drought severity
index shown here on oh sorry temperature
on the Left Palmer drought severity on
the right not surprisingly these early
years are hot years and they are dry
years but let me tell you what's
interesting is we can say how consistent
is this across time as this continued
across all different types of climate
epochs and with climate change so he
divided the data in two pieces 1950 so
all the data is 1602 before 1950 on the
left side just looking at the recent
period after 1950 on the right and this
is temperature again these composite
mean indexes so you see that the early
years before and after 1950 are hot
they're significantly hotter after 1950
because it's gotten much hotter in
Europe with climate change when we look
at that drought metric that soil metric
we see a shift so here it is before 1950
over on the left and here is after 1950
the more recent years over on the right
what you see is that drought used to be
a major driver of these early harvests
and very surprisingly to us it no longer
is so early harvests in France which are
still strongly correlated with higher
quality pricier wines are no longer for
some reason linked to drought and this
is a major question my lab is working on
currently
you